I think the obvious starting point for
discussing the look of silence is to
start with the act of killing the film
you made before this they're
dramatically different in terms of the
ways that they're made stylistically in
terms of the the people they focus on
and yet obviously there's a kinship
there so we should talk a little bit
about how this piece emerged out of that
one and what the relationship really was
like there well the first there's a
scene in the look of silence which
really inspired the making of both films
and it's the scene where the two men
take me down to the river taking turns
playing victim and perpetrator showing
how they can pretend pretending to be
proud I would emphasize pretending to be
proud of what they did is they take me
to the spot where they help the army
kill ten thousand five hundred people I
and then reveal that one of them killed
my friend's son and brother romley and
that was that I shot that scene in
january 2004 and it was the first time I
I was been shooting already with the
perpetrators for eight months at the
request of Adi his family and the other
survivors who had been threatened by the
army back in 2003 not to participate in
the film they then called me to the
secret nighttime midnight meeting and
said don't give up try to film the
perpetrators I was afraid to do so at
first but when I overcame that fear and
approach them I found this I encountered
this horrific boasting and I spent the
first eight months filming them
one-on-one because I didn't know if it
would be safe to bring two together one
might tell the other you shouldn't talk
about this and we could get in trouble
and the whole thing could stop before we
even really understood what had happened
where it happened how it happened and
but after around eight months I felt I
need to see if these men are only
boasting for me when I'm alone with them
or it's something about me and my camera
or would they talk this way with each
other and I took the risk of bringing
two men together and to film that scene
and I saw that they were even worse when
they were together that some
how they were clearly reading from a
shared script and the boasting therefore
I had to acknowledge is systemic is
political is a symptom of impunity and I
had to relinquish whatever hope I might
have comforting hope that these men are
psychotic or monsters whatever psychosis
or monstrosities is evidenced here is
political as well and collective and I
that that realization came to me
actually through the thought which I had
for the first time when I was walking
down to the river with those two men
that it's as though I've wandered into
Germany 40 years after the Holocaust
only to find the Nazis still in power if
the rest of the world had celebrated the
Holocaust while it was taking place and
I decided I had this awful sense that I
have this that this may not be some
surreal scenario from science fiction
this may not be this weird exception to
the rule it this idea of what if the
Nazis had one it actually actually there
been myriad at numerous massacres across
the global south where there's been no
justice where impunity prevails and
people live in fear and I started to
wonder whether perhaps this impunity is
the story of our times whether perhaps
the idea of what if the Nazis that one
is not the exception but the rule across
much of the world and I decided that
evening I would stop everything else I
was doing all my other projects and
focus on this on this impunity not on
what happened in 1965 1965 for as long
as necessary and I knew that very
evening I noted in my diary I'll make
two films one about the lies the
fantasies the stories the perpetrators
tell themselves so they can live with
themselves and the terrible effects of
those lies when imposed on the whole
society and that of course is the act of
killing and it's a film about escapism
and guilt and so it is a kind of
flamboyant fever dream of a film and I
knew I would make a second film though
which is asking what is it like
especially for the survivors but for any
human being to have to live in that
regime of corruption thuggery fear that
the perpetrators have built what is it
due to
beings to have to live for half a
century in silence and in fear and the
act of killing there's an uncut that a
longer sort of the original uncut
version of the film is out in the US as
the director's cut but it it's the
version that was released outside the US
I only mention it because it's cut
through by these moments of absolute
silence and sort of war type moments
where time stops and it's these moments
where the perspective shifts from the
perpetrators to the absent dead I think
and in the look of silence I had this
feeling that the audience should feel as
though they've entered any one of those
haunted silences that punctuate the act
of killing and feel what would it be
like to have to live there after as a
survivor rebuild a life in the rubble
surrounded by the still powerful men who
killed her loved ones what is it like
never to be able to grieve openly and
therefore never to be able to mourn and
heal and what is it like to what does
that do to a family to a human being to
our capacity to love that's the look of
sight it's a really powerful way of
talking about the symbiotic relationship
with the two films because they both
involve two very different kinds of risk
in the first film I think a lot of
people came out of it wondering why you
wouldn't confront these people about
these atrocities they were boasting
about and that's the essence of this
movie which makes one wonder you know
what were the conditions and under which
that could happen you know and how did
you manage with adi to go about making
that happen well so as I said Adi was
the person who I started this journey
with in 2003 and while I was filming the
perpetrators he would watch everything I
had time to show him and we shot the
look of thought we shot the look of
silence after editing the act of killing
but before it had its first screenings
at which point I knew I couldn't safely
return to Indonesia a couple years
before though we when we finished
editing when we finished shooting sorry
the act of killing I give a Nadia small
camera to use as a kind of visual
notebook for to look for images that
might inspire the making of the second
film and when I came back and while i
was editing the act of killing Adi was
sending me tapes when i returned to
indonesia
after after we finished the editing in
2012 to make the look of silence I
didn't know auti would be the main
character I just knew he would be a main
collaborator still and I sat down with
him and said what do you think we should
do for the second film and Adi said i
spent seven years watching the footage
you've shot with the perpetrators it's
changed me and I need to meet them I
need to go and confront the men who
killed my brother and I said instantly
absolutely not it's too dangerous there
has never been a non fiction film where
survivors confront perpetrators who are
still in power it's simply too dangerous
and Adi took out the carrots had let me
explain why this matters to me and took
out the camera that I'd given him and
took out a tape and he said I'm sorry
but I never sent you this tape because
it's very personal to me and he put it
in the trembling he put the tape in the
camera press play and as soon as the
image appeared on the the footage
appeared that he shot on the flip screen
of the camera before I could even really
see what it was he started to cry and
what and he proceeded to show me the one
seen in the look of silence that Adi
shot and it's the scene where his father
at the end is crawling through the house
lost calling for help and he said Joshua
this was the first day my father
couldn't remember me my brother's my
sister's my mother and he was calling
for help lost confused all day and when
we would try to help him we were
strangers to him and he would only grow
more afraid and it was unbearable to sit
there watch it waiting for him to get
better not being able to do anything and
at some point not knowing what else to
do i picked up the camera and then
filmed i had it he said because he had
it because it was a sort of family
reunion and while filming he said the
moment i started to film i understood
why i was filming i was filming because
this is the day that it becomes too late
for my father to heal he's forgotten the
Sun whose murder destroyed his life
destroyed our family's life but he
hasn't forgotten the fear and now he
will never be able to
work through that fear and he'll because
he can't remember what happened and so
and so I feel like he said my father's
like is now trapped in this prison of
fear like a man locked in a room who
can't remember even where the door is
let alone where he's put the key and
then we watched the scene in silence as
it finished and at the end he looked at
me and said Josh Joshua I do not want my
children to inherit this prison of fear
from my father my mother and from me and
I think if i visit the perpetrators
they'll see that i'm not there for
revenge I'm not there out of anger and
they'll greet this as an opportunity to
make peace with their neighbors to find
forgiveness from one of their victims
relatives and they will acknowledge what
they did was wrong and I'll forgive them
and in that way finally we will be able
to live with our neighbors no longer
afraid but as human beings